there are some reports during this
period however of Bob's safe houses
being attacked by entire hit squads but
the reports have certain individuals
sometimes even entire operation simply
vanishing as if they were never there
now one soldier no matter how skill
simply is not enough senator it's like
you people haven't heard a word I've
said
Lincoln played it smart always I need to
look at options come over the plan if
the best play was to silently neutralize
all the muscle and then join well he was
more than proficient in the art of the
covert takedown sometimes even left a
few breathing to have a chat with them
later I don't know anything let me tell
you senator the biggest weapon isn't
worth a damn if the other guy can take
it away from you before you even know
he's there if the smart move was to
trade blows make examples out of a few
guys and no one did public and brutal
like Lincoln quiet last place in the
world you'd want to be is in a fistfight
with that man it didn't matter how hard
to hit him he never ever stop moving
forward muscle alone doesn't make you
ruthless you have to be willing to fight
and claw and scrape and do it no one
else will do to stay alive
imagine being trapped in a dark room and
there's no way out and every fear have a
nightmare you have a hand in that region
there's no escape from any of if you are
vulnerable to being surgically picked
apart from a distance but no amount of
guards would keep Lincoln from staying
low probing for weakness and finding the
perfect sight line if the situation was
less subtle then he could go in guns
blazing you've never seen shock and awe
like that gentleman and all of Green
Angel of Death the truth is to his
enemies Lincoln Clay was a walking
nightmare he could hurt Sal marcano and
is true in a hundred different ways one
thing we do agree on senator no matter
how it happens all that really matters
about any
and who's left standing when it's over
you